uh anyway so this is not larsa's talk he
is in room five I have been moved here
didn't get the memo
so I was over in Lars this room five
minutes ago
and he's like didn't you get the email
you're in room two okay so I made it on
time always good this is the Blazer
server side deep dive and I know it says
Carl Franklin's blazer cookbook up there
but what I've done is I don't have any
slides I have a document in HTML
document with code snippets and
directions and links and images and I'll
be giving that to you guys so you can do
exactly what I'm doing here when you
leave here today I've been I got on the
blazer bandwagon pretty early on the
server side
anyway the webassembly thing I've been
taking a closer look at lately but I've
been messing around with the server side
stuff since the last summer I I was so
enamored of it that I went and redid all
the podcasts back-end web stuff that I
had written previously in vanilla
JavaScript and HTML and web api but I
redid the front-end in like a man week I
was like I have never felt so productive
in my life with a with a front-end web
technology not even web forms this is
just blowing blowing it out of the water
for me so I'm going to show you we're
gonna build an application you know it's
not going to do a whole lot but it's
going to exercise all of the the things
that I've learned over the past months
and we'll be going down into the system
and take a look at what's really going
on under the hood which is what I think
you're really really interested in so
this as I said is a cookbook this is
from my my online workshop that I've
have been doing and just a little part
of it it's a
day workshop and the link is here so
what I'm going to do is just follow the
instructions and I'm going to create a
new project in Visual Studio 2019 and
it'll be a blazer app call band Booker
so the whole idea here for this big
application is that yeah so this is
going to allow us to define instruments
like piano guitar drums then musicians
that have that play those instruments
and then bands that have those musicians
in them and the venues where the bands
play and then bookings which links all
of those things together links you know
abandon a venue and a date and the
particular musicians of that band
they're gonna play that gig and the
whole idea came out because I am in a
band and trying to get everybody in the
band together it's a 10-piece band
trying to get everybody together to
accept or reject a gig that comes along
in a timely manner by email is just a
big pain it just doesn't work and so you
know when some when my brother asks hey
is you know such and such playing this
gig I'm like I don't know now I have to
go search through Google Gmail and find
you know where they said yea or nay it
was just a big problem so I figured this
was a nice little exercise to go through
this building this app so that's what
we're gonna do
call band Booker
and you know like all blazer
server-side blazer apps oh that's
awesome
all right cool so let me let me do this
again I don't know why that happened but
let me do this again it might be that
there's already a project in that
directory I don't know why I was in the
dev intersection directory okay so this
is gonna be your your standard demo
first as long as this runs all right so
let's find a good place for it here we
go
band Booker blazer server app this is
the latest and greatest vigil studio
I'll be talking about the differences
between client side and server side as
well the first I want to just show you
the quintessential blazer demo which is
the counter where you press a button and
it updates a counter and we'll just take
a look at what's going on under the hood
here so you can see I'm updating this
counter I got this click Me button and
every time I click it increments alright
simple event and so let's take a look
and see what's going on under the hood
yeah this is the code right here for the
counter page which I will pull up here
so let's look at this what's going on
here is we've got just an HTML button
right and rather than an on click
without an @ sign we have an at on click
that @ sign basically is a blazer
directive that's saying hey this is
going to run code on the server and
blazars got to handle this
rather than javascript if we left out
the @ it would be just a JavaScript on
click so then you have this @ code block
it doesn't have to be in the razor page
itself you can do code behind and I'll
show you how to do that but it there it
is you have a current count you have a
increment count which increments that
number and we're just displaying that in
HTML and there's the current count so no
doubt you guys have seen this before not
too interesting but let's talk about the
difference between client side blazer
and server side blazer if this was
client side blazer that code would be
running in the browser right and it
would be compiled to webassembly
bytecode essentially it's not really
compiled it's sort of interpreted but
you get the idea the code is actually
c-sharp running in the browser here
we're on the server okay so how does
that happen well the magic of that is
signal our and signal our is a web is a
WebSockets framework right it uses
WebSockets but it can also use other
means of doing what sockets do if you've
ever done any sockets programming
sockets are the underlying architecture
the transport your your the way that all
Internet programming applications that
use the internet like browsers and email
clients that that's how they access
tcp/ip is through a socket and you know
when a browser makes a request to a web
site it opens a socket connection and
then it you know sends a request it gets
a response and then that connection is
closed by the server whereas with signal
are we're using a web socket that is
connected and it stays connected and it
stays open and as long as that socket is
open the client can send data to the
server server can send data back to the
client it's a two-way persistent
connection so this all happens magically
for you under the hood so rather than
when you click that button rather than
making an HTTP request to a server and
getting some some JSON back and then
with JavaScript sort of changing the Dom
yourself what happens is it goes over
that signal our connection and the
server is keeping a graph in memory of
the Dom of the browser for every client
so it knows the state of the Dom in the
browser executes the code and then does
a diff in the in that graph on the
server to find out what has changed UI
wise in the browser and then it sends
back over that same signal our
connection all of the information that
Blaser needs to update the UI in the dom
okay so all of this happens very quickly
and very actually inexpensively in terms
of performance and in terms of data
that's actually traveling back and forth
it's actually very efficient
so that's the big difference between
server-side Blaser and client-side
Blaser and there's just a couple of
things to consider here the the hosting
model of the server has a few benefits
I've already outlined the but download
size significantly smaller they you know
the start-up size basically when you run
it you're you don't have to ship down
the you know the blazer runtime which is
about four megabytes now but they're
looking to get that under two megabytes
so the app loads faster since
everything's running on the server you
can take advantage of all of that the
server has to offer code wise including
the architecture right so you can access
your data stores and all of that stuff
without having to you know without being
required to use a Web API or some other
rest interface to get data because
you're already on the server so there's
that advantage and then of course it
works on every just about every browser
and even ones that don't support web
assembly so the downsides are that
there's there may be latency issues
because you are making a network hop for
every interaction no offline support so
if your users aren't connected to the
Internet or the internet connection goes
down the application will cease to
function and scalability has its own
challenges with with signal arm but
we'll talk about that also an asp net
core server is required not necessarily
a big deal these days this is a slide
that I stole from Ryan Nowak who works
in the asp net core team and was
according to him the second person to
ever work on the blazer project so just
by comparison let's talk about bandwidth
and how much bandwidth these things
consume streaming video is perhaps the
worst
at 4k we're talking a lot you know what
is that
53 megabytes I don't know what Ted is
with 53,000 kilobytes that's 53
megabytes per second thousand kilobytes
per second for 320p
and audio streaming audio is about 160
kbps but Blaser server one operation
takes about 0.5 kbps so it really is
pretty efficient and if you want to take
a look at the signal our traffic I wrote
a blog post here on app V next where I
show you how to log the signal our
traffic that's going back and forth over
the wire and we actually look and look
at some of it as it's being logged and
there's not a whole lot but it is
interesting nonetheless if you're into
if you're into that figuring out what
what's going over the wire alright so
the difference between blazer
server-side blazer and your traditional
asp net core raise our application MVC
application is completely different
right so when a razor page or views
rendered every line of that razor code
emits HTML in text form and then the
server disposes of that page or view
instance including any state that was
produced and another request for the
page occurs for instance when validation
fails the entire page is rerender to
HTML again and the page is sent to the
client so there's a lot more traffic
going back and forth with an MVC
application than with a blazer server
application we're basically talking
about a spa where you don't have to do
any of the goo of accessing data in your
web api and updating the client so
that's the magic of blazer server so
let's talk about scaling Microsoft did
some tests and it turns out that just
without
your code or your state or your data
every connected client requires about
85k of overhead and this is a screenshot
from Dan Roth's video that he did a
dotnet conf they did this test for
appropriate latency and with with active
concurrent clients and they used two
different instances server on in Azure
right the the D 1 V 2 standard which is
3.5 gigs of RAM could handle 5,000
concurrent active users but if they
upgraded that to a 14 gig server with 4
V CPUs 20,000 plus so also right we'll
talk about scaling out signal are but
the real bottleneck seems to be memory
right so more memory means you can
handle more concurrent clients with your
with your data so they found in this
particular test which was a real test
with real data that we got up to like
250 K per of memory per client so it's a
little bit different you got to do the
math and think about that
so to conserve memory usage you want to
pay attention to how much memory is
being used in your app per client right
so the worst thing you could do is allow
the client to load up you know a million
records from your database in object
form put them in a list and then display
them right in a select that would be the
worst because now every instance you
know every concurrent client connection
is taking up all of that memory so a
better idea is to use things like you
know search boxes to not allow more than
so many records to be displayed on the
page at once but you know this is this
should be standard procedure for you
now any days anyways as web developers
you probably already know that but it it
really you really have to pay attention
to it and blazer so in additional in
addition to memory available WebSockets
can also be depleted if the number of
concurrent clients exceeds the number
available signal are connections so to
scale that you might consider using the
Azure signal are service completely
offloading the signal our service to
assure so here's a link to an article
that explains how to make that happen
and you can read read this in your own
time but this basically shows you how to
provision a signal our service and Azure
and how to use the secret sauce to in
configuration to set your Azure
connection string and then you can see
it just works now we're talking about
the signal our service that blazer uses
internally that's what we're replacing
with as your signal arm so that's always
a good idea if you you know planning on
making a really big app alright so let's
talk about state let's go back to our
app here back to our old trusty counter
and you can see that this is working if
I go to another page like here's the
home page and then go back to the
counter what happened it's at zero again
so all of the state goes away when you
navigate to another page in server side
blazer that's what happens so you may
not want that and may be perfectly okay
but you may not want that behavior you
may want them to go to all the pages and
keep the state no matter what page they
go to so to ameliorate this we're going
to create a service and offload all the
state into the service which will live
one per client across all of the pages
and then we'll just inject that service
and use it wherever we want so we'll
make a class we'll add a class here
called app state and it's a very simple
class just has a clicks property alright
and now we're gonna go to the services
startup CS and the services and we're
gonna call add scoped for app state and
so this is how we're going to be able to
use this from wherever we are you can
see there's already ad singleton for the
weather forecast service that's another
demo I'll show you this one
the weather forecast service is just
simply a class that retrieves data and
every time you go there you'll see a
different random set of weather forecast
data okay but look at the difference
that weather forecast service is a
singleton where as we're adding app
state as scope
so the difference there is a singleton
has one instance that's shared across
all users all users all clients get the
same instance of that object whereas if
you do add scoped now it's per client
right so every every client gets this a
copy of this app state and wherever you
inject it you're accessing that same
instance for that client okay there's
another one
transient ad transient and that of
course there is no state that that is
just a per page lifecycle so that would
work exactly if we used it we work
exactly as the counter works right now
all right so let's update our counter
tracer to use this service and so you
can see I'm using the at inject
directive right here here's the type app
state and here's our variable app state
the current count has now at app State
clicks
increment count is still being called
but now instead of having a local
variable we're using that app state and
incrementing that
and now I can increment it no problem I
switched to home I come back to them
cool so that can be really important
it's probably maybe the one of the first
things that you would do in a real
application
so yeah just talking about these things
all right so let's talk about how
server-side Blaser handles unhandled
exceptions let's just create a an
exception here throw a new exception
ouch
all right so it'll break in Visual
Studio but let's just go and continue so
we can see more of like what would
happen in the real world and you can see
here an unhandled exception has occurred
see the browser dev tools for details
but guess what the app stops working the
connection has been severed and take a
look at this if we go to the browser
tools right connection disconnected
right there so here's the exception ouch
right that's good but this is the most
important thing to know begin and this
is by design that the signal our
connection has been completely severed
but it's by designed because you're now
your your code is now in a state that is
dangerous right it could be used as an
attack vector unhandled exception has
occurred that may have occurred you know
somewhere where you know there's
somebody's entering a credit card or
putting an order through all right we
don't know what the state of that is you
know if why would we allow the user to
continue to use the application it just
opens up all sorts of possibilities for
security threats so that's by design
alright so now let's get into the real
application here we're going to add a
couple of classes instrument and
musician I'll create a models folder
first
and add to that instrument
and now another one musician
all right so instrument basically has an
ID in a name musician has an ID and a
name and a list of instruments couldn't
be simpler
so let's do some UI for start starting
the UI to show a list of instruments and
then we'll get a little bit more into it
so I'm gonna go to index that razor
which is you know your first landing
page we're just going to modify that
first of all here's the mark up with a
select but let's go down to the code
first I have a list of instruments and
there's a few overrides that you can do
for lifecycle management one of them is
uninitialized it can be a sync if you
want it to be a sync this is obviously
you know when when everything's ready to
roll but there's another there's another
a few other ones one of them is on
parameters set which you can pass
parameters to pages alright and those
parameters are not set at uninitialized
so they won't exist yet but anyway we're
going to create a new list of
instruments and we're going to just set
some of these values in here guitar
keyboards bass and drums up here in the
Select right we have this at for each of
our instrument and instruments and we're
going to put an option in the Select for
each one of those set the value to the
ID and the text to the name and no
JavaScript
pretty cool huh all right
well let's continue so we're gonna add a
few buttons for new edit and delete
right below this select and we need
these methods now new instrument button
click Edit instrument button click and
delete button click we'll just create
those empty for now so we'll actually
run
and not doing too much here not at all
all right so let's continue and these
are you can see these don't have any
particular signature they're just void
all right so now we're going to add a
boolean disabled instrument edit button
because the initial state of this we
should not allow a user to click edit or
delete until one of the you know until
one of the items has been selected it
doesn't make any sense so that's how it
will look right up upfront yeah and now
we have to modify the edit and delete
button so that with the disabled
attribute so they can pay attention to
that right so disabled equals at disable
instrument edit to button so now these
guys are in their proper state for you
know now we have to do the rest of it
which is when one item is selected we
will enable those buttons so we have to
have a selected instrument let's do that
so we have a selected instrument and an
instrument selected method now this one
we're going to link in the UI in the
select but you notice that there's a
change event args here
and so the args value to string is going
to be past this value right there which
is the ID so now all I'm going to do is
do a little link and say the selected
instrument is from X and instrument
where the ID matches
and pull out the first one and then
disable or enable the buttons
accordingly so we have to modify the
select so that now on change calls
instruments selected that's the only
change right there boom our buttons
still don't do anything but now at least
the enable/disable behavior works
alright so before we go any further let
me show you how to do the code-behind
thing so of course you know if you're
looking at this there's a couple of
weird things first of all there's some
strange visual studio highlighting here
that that is just drives me nuts a
little bit I'm not sure why that is but
also some things don't work like if I
have a variable here and I hit you know
control period to pull up refactorings
nothing happens so this is a blatant
sign that you know you are not in the
real visual studio code editor here this
is the sort of a a modified half-assed
version of it so in order to do code
behind it's pretty easy you just
wherever your razor page is you add a
class that says what called you know
whatever the razor file is and then a
dot CS at the end so index dot razor dot
CS and look at that it's all nested and
everything's ready to go now the thing
is we can't call this index because
index is already a class for that razor
page so we actually have to rename it to
something else so I'm gonna call it
index code
so here's index code that has all of the
same code in it and also derives from
component base has all the same code in
it that we currently have in the code
block in the index page itself right our
blank button handlers our instruments
are uninitialized everything is exactly
the same now all we have to do is change
index razor to inherit from that code
and completely delete the code block so
now you can see inherits at inherits
index code everything else exactly the
same here's our instruments here's our
button but now we have this beautiful
full visual studio experience of editing
you know control period brings up the
refactorings all that stuff and of
course it works just like before
all right so another change we're going
to make is to show the selected
instrument as selected in the list
because now we have a selected
instrument all right so let's reflect if
it gets set right then we're going to
use the selected attribute otherwise
we're not going to use it okay so we're
going to start with the code to delete
an instrument and that's here in the
delete instrument button click so if the
selected instrument is not know in other
words we have one that's selected we're
going to remove that from our
instruments collection excuse me and
just an easy way out if we still have
instruments in the list we're going to
set the selected instrument to the first
one rather than trying to figure out you
know which one was before it or anything
like that I guess we could set it to
last might be better but you never know
you might be in the middle of the list
all right so let's just see if that
works oh it's not going to work yet
because we haven't wired up oh yeah yeah
we have yeah yeah no work all right so
drums delete there we go yeah that was
easy alright so now we're going to talk
about components we're going to actually
build a component that will allow us to
add an instrument or edit an instrument
you only field is name so when you see
it's going to be very simple but we will
be able to use it as a component and
after we do that for musician the
musician will have its own editor but it
will be using a generic component that
we can reuse with different types that's
going to be cool so we're going to add a
new component called instrument editor
and it's going to be a RZR component
it's a little bit different than what
you might think what you might think is
when you right-click on pages and say
add and it says raiser page that's not
what you want you want a new item over
in web a RZR component that's going to
give you a a blazer raiser component
instrument editor okay I'm just gonna
replace that with my clipboard
inheritance here so we have a boolean
show instrument panel this is one of our
our you know our methods I'm sorry our
our fields here and we have these things
called parameters these are essentially
public properties all right parameters
are how you pass data in and out from
your component to your calling code and
you also notice that three of these are
of type event callback so those are
essentially event handlers or you know
events that the calling code can handle
way different than your standard c-sharp
event model right easy actually much
easier all right well anyway we have one
four cancel pressed instrument added
instrument updated this component here
isn't actually going to do any
management of your instrument list or
any data access or anything like that
it's purely a UI component that's going
to allow you to change the name and then
it will you know then it has these
buttons one for submit and one for
cancel also notice that the text where
is it the text of the button submit
button text is is also something that we
can change right because you would
either be add or update depending
which one we're doing and then we have
public methods for a new instrument edit
instrument and we have the handlers for
the submit button pressed and the cancel
button pressed and this is how we invoke
the method invoked beat the event
instrument added invoke async so in here
we have these validation controls and
you might have noticed this that in this
div we have instead of an input tag we
have an input text tag and there's also
a couple things here that you may not
have seen before one is an edit form and
within that data annotations validator
and a validation summary so this is
blazars validation system and the the
edit form what's ever whatever is in an
edit form that tells Blaser okay we're
doing possible validation here the data
annotations validator says I want you to
validate against the annotations that
are in the model we don't have any yet
but we're gonna add them and we're gonna
say that the maximum length of that name
field can be 50 characters and that's it
so with using the input text it's
exactly like the input tag except that
it has this extra validation stuff and
you're going to use the bind value to
bind that so let's add some validation
to the instrument class that's a models
instrument
so we're gonna use the system component
model data annotations namespace we're
gonna add required as an attribute for
name so they can't get away with passing
anything and then we're also gonna say
that maximum number of characters is 50
and if they exceed that we even have an
error message here very cool so far all
right so now the instrument editor code
this is what I was just talking about
this sort of the tour of the code one
thing you might notice is that I have a
button type equals submit for the submit
button and button type equals button for
the cancel button if you didn't put this
in here you RAZR would treat the cancel
button also as a submit button and what
what you do with submit is right here on
valid submit equals submit button
pressed but it's only going to happen if
all the validations pass all right cool
so now let's go back to index raiser and
we'll add the mark up to instantiate
that component
all right so we have an instrument error
message we have to add we're gonna add
code for all of these things
I guess I'll come back to this after we
add that code so we get rid of the
squiggles in particular pay attention to
at ref so let me go to my code behind
here all right so we have an instrument
editor this is the component that we
just made instrument editor reference
called instrument editor and in a
message and all sorts of other things
going back to index now that @r f equals
instrument editor basically links our
code reference to this particular
instance of the component so that's how
we can grab a reference to the component
and then call methods on it these are
the parameters right here
instrument equals selected instrument so
we're passing instrument as a parameter
actually and cancel pressed and
instrument added instrument updated all
of those things also need to fill in the
button click handlers for new and edit
instrument which will be right here
and now we've also added a variable
called disable instrument list and you
can use that to enable and disable the
list of instruments while editing or
adding so that we can use to disable the
list because we don't want to select an
item and then say edit and then leave
this select statement enabled a select
tag enables so that the user can click
on another one
want that
now there's another thing here my code
does which is a stupid JavaScript script
trick for setting focus oh yeah maybe
it'll run right now maybe it won't let's
just see and I'll show you the
difference between these two all right
so I click on guitar and I edit there it
is but notice that the text guitar you
know this input is not in focus I have
to actually click on it before I can do
any editing would it be cool if it was
just in focus right but it turns out
there is no focus method you can call on
these tags right I can't I can't get a
reference to the actual tag itself
because that's in the DOM and they
generally frown on that so at this point
in time blazer doesn't support that in
the box but you can use JavaScript
Interop to achieve it
and talking to Steve Sanderson
he says that's most likely coming along
with some other things right so check
this out
I'm going to add some JavaScript to the
main file instead of having an
index.html we have an underscore host
CSS HTML and this is sort of the the
main page template for everything and
I'm going to add this script here so
I've got a window dot set focus method
and it passes an ID you know an ID of of
an element and instead of just calling
element dot focus and elements select
there you'll notice that I'm doing a
little trick here because we're going to
be calling this from a button click
handler right the element to edit won't
even exist when you're in that it won't
exist yet when
in that button handler so you have to do
some asynchronous trick trickery to make
this work so what I'm doing is I'm
calling this private function internal
focus with a 10 millisecond timeout and
there I get the element by ID but right
away the first time it's going to be no
and so then we're going to call
ourselves in another 10 milliseconds
with a set timeout and exit and so this
is going to keep going on until such
time as you know the element reference
comes back not know and then we'll set
the focus and select and yep it's kind
of a janky hack but it works and you
know let's just hope that we don't get
into an infinite loop there but that
would be your fault all right so here's
how we call JavaScript we inject this
ijs runtime and that's going to be an
instrument editor because that's where
we're doing this
IJ s runtime and then we have a variable
J s that we can use and here's the code
oh we have to give our input text
element an ID right instrument dot name
so let's do that that's this guy right
here
come on what you doing
I guess I selected that too all right
here we go
so ID instrument dot name because that's
what we're going to pass and now we're
going to in the new instrument and edit
instrument we're going to await J s in
invoke void async void because it
returns nothing but we could also do
invoke async and return a value so we
have that set focus that's what we're
going to call so that is new instrument
and edit instrument right there so now
they've changed to have the async and
return a task which is nothing and now
when we say new instrument and edit
instrument we show the panel we can do
that set focus a little trick
mm that would be the same in webassembly
blazer as well
nothing server-side about that okay what
that actually work let's say we go back
to index raised RCS okay
make sure
keyboards keyboard update yeah yeah it
worked okay and we can delete so we can
also add there we go so our basic crud
operations are working so now let's talk
about generic components this is really
cool the musician editor has you know
the name but it also has that list of
instruments right so I have this another
blog post that I wrote before well I'll
grab this code first and this is
publicly available too in this blog post
which is links right down here oh man
there's a lot of code here I'll just go
to it it's an object picker dot blazer
I'm sorry dot app fie next dot com
here's the blog post so that is what the
UI looks like right you have the list of
all instruments on the left the selected
instruments on the right all of the
names of the instruments and when you
select one you can add a single one had
all of them or deselects all of them and
it moves the instruments from one side
to the other but the cool thing is this
is such a reusable component because I
don't want it just to be hard-coded for
instruments I want to be able to use
that for you know musicians in the band
editor right what musicians are in this
band I want to be able to pick musicians
so I wanted a generic thing and that's
exactly what we have here so we're going
to build a generic component called
object picker and let's just go do that
and I am object picker so the magic of
this starts with type / M
at type parameter I'm using this type in
here is inferred okay and here's where
it's inferred I have parameters which
again are properties right so I have
this list of selected items which is a
list of T item this is a parameter so
I'm gonna pass in my list of instruments
it's gonna say ah T item is now
instrument so anywhere we're using T
item as a as a type we know it's going
to be an instrument so I have the string
property item type which we're gonna set
to instrument and then plural which will
be instruments right so this is just for
UI purposes so we can say all
instruments and selected instruments the
text property name of the instrument
which is what shows up in the list I'm
going to use reflection for this so that
would be name and the value property
name which would be ID so we have our
list of all items in our list of
selected items that we start with okay
now we've got a tea item property
selected item which is going to be
instrument in our case and then all of
the code to pull out the value or the
text is right there with a little bit of
reflection item value of a of an item
returns the get type get property of the
value get value to string and the same
with the text now remember I told you
about this override on parameters
this is a good example of when you would
use that you can't use on initialize
because you don't know what T item is T
item is a parameter that's passed in
right so as soon as the code sets that
all items are selected items this is
going to this is going to fire so we'll
have well know that all items is an
instrument we're not going to have
anything hard-coded in here we're going
to use T item you know the ID all of
that so the mark-up itself is just a
table right of course could be anything
you could be using you know bootstrap
grids or whatever but this one's just
the table and then you've got the
buttons the list on each side the
handlers all that it's pretty cool
where the heck was I oh yeah yeah I am
alright so now we're going to create
musician editor which is going to have
an instance of this in it pages and new
item musician editor alright so this is
going to have the same kind of thing as
the instrument editor except that after
the name we're we have our object picker
instance and now we have all items
selected items right these are all based
on what we have in here so we're passing
in all instruments we have a selected
instruments somewhere
all right edit add submit button pressed
all that got our JavaScript focus all
right so now we're going to create a few
mission a few musicians in that index
file in the code behind where we have
this we'll get rid of that and replace
it so now we're adding the instruments
but we're also adding musicians piano
Patti shredding Shelly
thumping Pheo and banging Bob guess what
instruments they play all right so now
we'll add the rest of the code in the
index code behind to support the
musician UI right there and this is you
know the same stuff that you've seen
before delete musician button click
musician selected edit musician
cancelled added updated all that stuff
all the goo and the markup to edit
musicians goes in the index file itself
right below the instrument editor all
right so here's our musician select
here's our new button edit button delete
button and then our musician the editor
component we have a reference to it
everything should be good in the world
so and the rest of this code just shows
what that the rest of this document just
shows what the object picker is it goes
through all the code in there
all right so we got our musicians here
piano Patti let's edit piano Patti piano
Patti plays keyboards gonna update
shredding Shelley plays guitar and of
course you know these all work as
expected there's a lot of enabling and
disabling of buttons going on here thump
and Theo plays bass banging Bob plays
drums
all right let's what's that a new
instrument kazoo I knew a musician
creepy Carl plays kazoo there you go
and so if I you know I can edit these
and you can see that they're associated
accordingly
all right so in the three minutes that
are left I'll take any questions you
might have comments concerns yeah oh
yeah yeah check this out
styling look at this bootstrap that
bootstrap min CSS right there just
change it to your favorite bootstrap CSS
file and everything updates everything
changes
yeah that's what they use in terms of
using other CSS things like sass and all
that I would urge you to check out the
sessions at dotnet can't focus on blazer
because uh one of the guys there did a
great session on all the CSS things that
you can do with blazer anyone else
question yeah
does the server know about it yes yeah
yeah and that's the whole there's a
whole Interop layer but between
JavaScript and blaze are just for that
purpose
yeah and can go back the other way too
javascript can call netcode so yeah
javascript is dead long live javascript
anyone else yeah
no that's a good question can you
generate type constraints you know like
say I only want you know to allow i
observables or whatever no you can't but
what did Ryan say about that I think he
said that that is something that they're
working on because a lot of people want
that feature yeah else you like it it's
good right it's good all right I'll see
you later
Thanks
[Applause]